[Music]
no matter how much we love to watch our
favorite cartoons we have to admit that
we were disappointed by some of them
stay tuned until the end to see how the
creators of South Park totally messed up
the show if you love cartoons as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 10 HIGHlarious
ly bad cartoon episodes from your
favorite shows SpongeBob SquarePants
1 course meal punch Bob Squarepants used
to be one of the most popular shows on
Nickelodeon however there is at least
one time when they clearly messed up and
left kids all around the world
traumatized after watching this episode
if you are too sensitive please don't
watch one course meal in this episode
plankton tried to steal the recipe once
again but mr. Krab was quickly saved by
Plankton's biggest fear whales in case
you didn't know Wells eat plankton and
mr. Krabs daughter happens to be a whale
even though we don't really understand
why anyway the restaurant owner decided
to take advantage of the situation by
pretending to be a whale to scare
plankton the evil character ended up
being so terrified that he became
delusional kept having nightmares and
became depressed giving up on his
biggest dream we had never seen him like
this before and the situation kept
getting worse plankton asked himself
what was the point of going on and just
lied on the road waiting for the bus to
run over him luckily for plankton
spongebob was there to save him but we
can't imagine what the episode would
have been like if he wasn't so nice you
should never see a character trying to
end his life on a kids show the loud
house no such luck the loud house is now
the most popular show on Nickelodeon but
can you believe that one episode was so
bad that fans wanted it to be banned how
can they turn something so good into
something so bad and no such luck
Lincoln wanted to make sure that he
wouldn't be invited to any of his
sister's activities that's because with
10 sisters his calendar was booked every
day with stuff and he wanted some time
to himself but we all know that he was
finally forced to encourage his sisters
however they quickly regretted this
decision when they understood that
Lincoln was bad luck they started
talking about this and this is why he
was banned from all the activities
Lincoln thought that it was fun to have
some time for himself but he quickly
understood that he didn't like being
rejected all the time he wasn't only
banned from his sister's activity no one
wanted to be
him anymore including his parents he
couldn't even sleep in the house anymore
and the family ended up locking him
outside what was supposed to be funny
ended up being actually sad we think
that a loud house took this story a
little too far this time fairly
oddparents it's a wishful life if you
can make any of your wishes come true
what would it be would you like to have
100 million dollars and make even more
dreams come true without money but if
you ever watched Fairly OddParents
you'll know that you should be careful
what you wish for timmy was doing his
best to make people happy but he kept
failing over and over again no matter
how hard he tried this is why Timmy wish
that he was never born to see how
miserable everyone would be without him
but he quickly saw that everyone was
happier without him including his
parents who became rich and had a
wonderful daughter Cosmo and Wanda
seemed to be helping a much better kid
too this is why Timmy was forced to join
the place for useless children go but he
didn't want to go there and this is why
he decided to prove that at least one
person was less happy without him but it
turns out to be harder than what he
thought wouldn't it be sad to see that
everyone is happier without you when we
think that many kids already feel this
way we think that it was not fun to
laugh about this situation it was just a
test but it ended up being much more
stressful than a math exam the Powerpuff
Girls moral decay you would think that
nothing could go wrong with girls made
of sugar spice and everything nice right
but don't forget that Chemical X was
added to the mix and this is why there
might be a little something bad inside
them the girls worked cleaning up the
house to help the professor and he gave
them a dollar to thank them however
Buttercup was a little too happy to
finally have money and even said that
she understood why Mojo Jojo liked it so
much this is how she ended up
accidentally hurting bubbles but it
wasn't that bad when she understood that
she would get money every time she lost
a tooth this is when Buttercup became
crazy and ended up hurting her sisters
to get their teeth the professor told
her that it was not the right thing to
do and the young girl ended up using the
teeth of villains instead she used a lot
and a lot of teeth to get more and more
money this is why blossom and bubbles
decided that they would let the villain
to break all of buttercups teeth and the
professor used the money she earned to
pay her dental bills that was a terrible
lesson to be learned
gravity falls dipper versus manliness in
dipper versus manliness dipper had to
play a game to prove that he was strong
and manly enough to win some pancakes
unfortunately no one believed that he
could be mailing in any way and he found
out that they might be right when he
lost the game
mrs. why'd dipper had to find another
way to prove that he was manly and it
turned out that a really manly Minotaur
he met in the forest was going to help
him and teach him the secrets of
manliness first dipper had to change his
name to destructor he also had to learn
what pain was become stronger and face
his fears but he had to pass a final
test a really deadly one he had to find
the highest mountain and come back with
the head of the multi-bear he did spare
the life of the bear and learn something
from it but he still had a bad influence
for the rest of the episode we think
that there is no such thing as manliness
and no one should ever care about that
American Dad
shallow vows we are not really sure that
this show represents Americans as we
don't have an alien and a talking fish
at home Stan and Francine are probably
one of the most iconic couples on
television this is why they decided to
get married again for the 20th
anniversary but then Francine learned
that Stan married her just because she
was beautiful and she was really upset
she decided to stop her beauty regimen
to show him what she really looks like
when she didn't make any effort but Stan
just ran away from the wedding he
couldn't stop thinking about how ugly
she looked this is why he decided to
have his retinas removed and become
completely blind so he wouldn't see her
anymore
that didn't make him a better lover but
Francine wasn't really pleased when she
understood that a blind guy couldn't
work to earn money or take care of her
this is how they found out that they
both had bad reasons to get married she
wanted a provider and he wanted a pretty
wife that's not what we call a love
story
Futurama Anegada Delilah with a title
like that it's not a surprise that this
episode didn't work well unfortunately
you can't really understand what
happened in this episode by looking at
the title and this is why we'll have to
tell you more about this in this episode
the earth was doomed and the professor
was the last option the president had a
death spear was threatening the planet
and they wanted to destroy it with a
small spaceship Leela was the first one
to volunteer and Daffy had to make sure
that he
be with her to do nothing else but be
with her they failed and ended up on a
planet together where they were nothing
but leaves for a reason that we don't
really understand it didn't take too
much time for the viewers to understand
that they were Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden the earth was destroyed
and they thought that they were the last
two humans in the universe this is why
they decided that they had to build a
new world there but Lila later found out
that it was just another of Zapp's plans
to take advantage of her this is why she
ended up taking advantage of him that
episode was nothing but uninteresting
and unpleasant to see The Simpsons Lisa
goes gaga
we love The Simpsons and Lady gaga this
is why we were really happy to see that
our favorite singer was going to be part
of our favorite show unfortunately some
fans so that the problem was that she
actually stole the show the popstar was
simply going to Springville to entertain
people in this boring city but during
this time Lisa was finding out that no
one liked her and things were getting
worse Lady Gaga saw that someone was
suffering and this is why she decided
she had to help her everyone was waiting
for the pop star to come out of the
train but Gaga couldn't forget about one
of them she wanted to make sure that
Lisa was feeling better before she left
the city
she told the young girl that Lisa should
become Lisa's number-one fan and also
kissed Marge anyway while little
monsters probably thought that it was a
great episode fans of The Simpsons
didn't like to see that it was only
about the singer and didn't even
understand most of the references it's
fun to see a celebrity make a cameo on
the show but we want the Simpson family
to be more important we are happy to see
that the creators of the show learns
from this Family Guy life of Brian we
all loved Brian and we can't imagine an
episode without him so how can they
decide to get rid of him in one of the
episodes this time Stewie decided to
destroy his time machine because going
back in the past was too dangerous but
he quickly regretted it when Brian
passed away in a terrible and very
graphic accident we just couldn't
believe that one of our favorite
cartoons had killed one of the best
characters it was really sad to see that
the whole family had to say goodbye to
him one less time and to see Brian say
his last words we have to admit that we
are one of those viewers who cried while
watching this episode unfortunately
Stewie couldn't go back in time
that he has destroyed his time machine
this is why the family decided to move
on by adopting another dog it was
already hard enough to get rid of one of
the main characters and the Griffon
seemed to like him even more than Brian
it's never okay to make the viewers cry
like that when we're supposed to be
watching something fun Southpark pip
some people hate every episode of South
Park and we think that this is simply
because they don't really understand
this kind of humor however the biggest
fans of this cartoon had to admit that
they didn't like this episode either
first the episode started with an
introduction by Malcolm McDowell who
became a useless character for the rest
of this terrible story we didn't even
see our favorite characters as this
whole episode was based on a poor orphan
named pip one day he met a young girl
named Estella and fell in love with her
but unfortunately he feared that she
could never marry someone like him this
is why he decided that he was going to
do whatever it takes to become a
gentleman but that was never enough to
make a Stella fall in love with him he
would later learn that she just wanted
to break his heart any fan of South Park
will have to admit that this was the
worst episode that they ever created we
didn't learn anything from it and it
wasn't even fun can you think about any
other episodes of your favorite show
that was hilariously bad don't be shy to
answer in the comment section down below
and that's it for 10 hilarious bad
cartoon episodes from your favorite
shows for more stories like this don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]